welcome
welcome to fox news primetime i'm maria
bartiromo
tonight executive order sweep the most
aggressive executive orders in
presidential history
continued today with a focus on the
climate and our energy industry
today joe biden continued to chip away
at trump's economic legacy
with three new executive orders designed
to quote
tackle the climate crisis at home and
abroad
the president claims we can address the
quote existential threat of climate
change
while revitalizing the economy as well
when i think of climate change i think
of the answers to it i think of
jobs a key plank of our buildback better
recovery plan
is building a modern resilient climate
infrastructure
and clean energy future that will create
millions of good
paying union jobs
so why are so many energy executives
expecting millions of high-paying jobs
to go away
with that stroke of pen the president's
commitment to the american worker might
be more believable if not for last week
when he killed the keystone pipeline and
the 11 000
jobs that came along with it they say
they want us to
to move toward a cleaner future and a
cleaner type of energy but
the problem is the people that are
they're losing their jobs right now
it's devastating to see this happen to
american
workers well just like a kick in the
stomach that you know
knocks the wind out of you you come look
at them in the face
and tell them that uh you know i just
for just one stroke
of the pen kill eleven thousand
high-paying jobs but if any of those
workers
dare blame joe biden for losing their
livelihoods they better think again
new climate czar john kerry says it's
not joe's fault
that they're out of work it's the market
forces
workers have been fed a false narrative
no surprise right for the last few years
they've been fed
the notion that somehow dealing with
climate
is coming at their expense no it's not
what's happening to them is happening
because of other market forces already
taking place
john kerry is betting on china changing
its behavior and not being the biggest
polluter in the world to move the needle
on climate
as if beijing keeps any promises to
anyone in its quest to overtake the
united states
as the number one superpower gen